hello Carol hey youtubers its charlie
let's break bad together I mean let's do
mess together I mean let's talk about
Breaking Bad together that's right it's
the first episode of the last season of
Breaking Bad or the ninth episode of the
fifth season but whatever bah bah bah if
you haven't been watching Breaking Bad
it's all on Netflix right now so you
should catch up because we're in the
last eight episodes of the series
without spoiling things too much it
basically takes place a few years in the
past between say like 2005 and 2007 so
what we're seeing on the show has
already happened
although the show deals mostly with blue
meth it's really all about the rise and
fall of Walter white played by Bryan
Cranston so it's basically the
chronicling of this rise to power of
this normal guy named Walter White to
this super villain and then his eventual
demise so right now we're in the last
eight episodes we're obviously dealing
with his demise so even though we don't
know how the series is going to end yet
I have some theories based on some of
the things that happen in this first
episode of these last eight so just in
case you haven't seen any of the
episodes prior to this or you haven't
watched season four yet or the first
half of season 5 be sure to turn the
volume down right now I'll tell you when
to turn it back up so how cool was it
that we get to start in the future we
got to see crazy beard Walt with these
crazy glasses and obviously the neighbor
that he runs into on his way into his
house is totally freaked out and clearly
by the skateboarding montage we learned
that his houses can now condemned
basically like what happens to meth
houses when police find them they
basically shut them down and they get
quarantined
so obviously something really terrible
has happened to Walt I felt like that
opening scene was followed by one of the
best moments in the episode it's
basically a follow up to where the last
season left off and Hank had just kind
of discovered and it was putting the
pieces together on who Walter White
really was obviously he comes out and he
looks like he's seen a ghost and he
begins to build this case against Walt
and so clearly these last eight episodes
are going to see that play out one of
the things that I wasn't really
surprised by was where Jesse's character
was obviously we've seen him kind of
down in the dumps and really depressed
before and I don't know about you but
I've always felt like the character
Jesse's character has always either been
on the edge of an overdose or suicide
he's basically like the moral
Center of the show now even though he's
the one that brought Walter into the
world of crime and into the meth world I
feel like at this point in the story
Jessie really does look towards Walt as
a father figure and even though he
probably knows that Walt's lying to him
he still wants to believe him just
because he needs a father so badly but
speaking of Walt lying do you feel like
Walt actually believes his own lies
Vince Gilligan the creator has talked
about how he doesn't really sympathize
with Walt anymore just because he's full
of so much he basically lies to
everyone around him and he even says in
the episode wall says in the episode
that he'll say anything to win an
argument so how do you believe anything
that he says let me know if you think
that Walt is actually going to end the
series in this really cliche moment of
honesty where he just opens up about all
the terrible things he's done like the
ricin poisoning and just killing
everyone around him or if you think it's
gonna be a little bit more subtle
personally I think that he's actually
just going to keep lying I mean it's
just so much of a part of his character
right now I think that he's going to end
with the most epic lie ever obviously
I'm not really sure what that lies going
to be but let me know what you think if
there was an Olympics for lying then
Walt would definitely win the gold medal
he does so many mental gymnastics to
kind of get himself through these
situations it's really hard to know
where the character of Heisenberg ends
and the character of Walt begins it is
definitely not going to end well for him
and you can turn the volume back up now
pull you back up Lee the way if you
haven't seen the teasers basically Walt
is on the run now Hank is on to him
obviously we don't know how that's going
to play out we've seen future Walt and
it kind of looks like he's been without
a bath for about three weeks so clearly
he's on the run in some way but let me
know what you think how is this going to
play out don't you really just feel like
these last eight episodes are just gonna
be like a slow-moving train wreck and
we'll just all have our eyes just glued
to the television it'll be amazing to
watch and just so terrible at the same
time though like I said all the episodes
of Breaking Bad up to where we are right
now are on Netflix so be sure to watch
it so we can talk about it I'm not going
to do Breaking Bad videos every week but
I'll do want every couple weeks just
because the show is so serialized I'm
also in the middle of a big Legend of
Korra contest right now you can click
here to get the details from that and
you can click here to see all the action
from Disney's d23 this weekend there was
so much Tom Hiddleston so much awesome
Marvel stuff so be sure to
check it out thanks for watching high
fives don't you men seriously it's
terrible